hi I'm Dave and I'm from New York today
I'm meeting a total stranger and for
some reason we're going to Times Square
I am sim well Swanson I am from a little
small dot called pine level Alabama this
is my first time in New York City oh
there was a Chipotle yeah I'm terrified
this is a show where we take two
strangers a local from the big city I've
lived in New York for about ten years
and an ounce of tannin
let's go guys guys go they go to one of
the most infamous spots in New York City
Times Square Dave absolutely hates Times
Square
I hate Times Square but Samuel could not
be more excited the goal is for Dave two
wits and a trip to Times Square and find
one thing he doesn't hate about it
this is tourists versus local I've lived
in New York for about ten years where
I'm from there's no Starbucks there's no
Burger King there's no bodega you guys
call it everyone is in a trailer so we
really don't seem break and if you do
have brick it's because you're either
bougie or you're rich in Times Square
I'm really excited to see characters
elmo's they're trying to steal money
from you it's awful it's awful I'm gonna
be able to go to Broadway shows
I Got News for you it costs like $120 to
see a Broadway show and that's for the
shittiest one do you think you're gonna
see Hamilton yeah good luck it costs
$2,000 to see Hamilton shopping maybe
going out on the street and about maybe
get some cool dope awesome jobs versus
working out of McDonald's or at the
county some awesome things I'm hoping to
see here maybe even Alicia Keys I would
love to see beyond today I don't know if
she's here or not or Kelly Rowland it's
loud it's expensive smells bad
discounted items could have like a Gucci
bag for like 20 bucks
I'm a cop me one cuz you never know
honey stun it until you make it great
food I mean there's probably some hot
dogs that are like three decades old you
could get there I'm ready to see crazy
hairstyles and crazy
I think Samwell hey bring it in what's
not buddy you do it
welcome come on in it's five flights up
okay there's an elevator right nope
Gracie's I'm already feeling it bro we
got two more
let's hit nuclei isn't it three we can
do it yeah I got calves of Steel I'm
gonna go down this little tunnel
[Music]
[Music]
like any places you like going in Times
Square the best part about Times Square
is when you finally leave Times Square
and you're free again I mean I'm a fun
outgoing person so you know but I love
the simple things in life so if I steal
a little monkey and you've probably seen
it eight times bro we're gonna have to
stop it we saw a little monkey running
around in Times Square
it'll be awesome I want to make you like
Times Square buddy like hands out and
you're gonna have fun with me so there's
no way I have no idea what the tests are
no you want to do yes I will open it
yeah snake ventures like Steven universe
oh wow so we have to buy a hot dog from
a street vendor and eat it on the curb
that's gonna be fantastic bro I've
always wanted to have like a New York
dog is that what you guys call it New
York dog can we call it New York
diarrhea oh there isn't a pole name oh
[ __ ] anti Starbucks Dave you ready to
get out now yes it's very garden this
right over there okay
that's sweet oh [ __ ] looks like a prison
yeah it looks awful yeah so we'd say hey
Dave
I'm so well Judah let's go over here man
what's that right there
is amazing this is New York City bro
like I'm still sick and seeing a tree I
love all the billboards I've all alight
and then do weight advertising you
definitely want to go see that bro we're
in time quit
hey buddy can we get a hotdog two of
them I'm excited to get this hot out
your bum for this row I'm so excited for
this hotdog okay I'll take a small hot
dog
thank you how much high dollars a $9 hot
dog growling this is like a play hot dog
we know bigger is better
[Music]
okay it's good now Alabama hot my
grandma said never let food go away so
thanks buddy
oh it's a tax to having trouble with
envelope huh take a photo with a costume
character
elmo's there oh dude that's amazing bro
picture take a picture click plan
what's up Mickey Mouse I swear he's
Latino Latino bla hoonjae's you have
different types of Mickey Mouse's here
all around the globe
awesome Cinco de Mayo was amazing
yesterday one day
without love
I was terrifying we were just attacked
by a bunch of Minnie Mouse's my heart
was pounding I thought I was gonna be
hurt but thank God we made it out safely
and now we're finally on to test number
three three he's been here 40 minutes
but it feels like we've been here 40
hours what's in envelope number three I
don't know what's in envelope number
three but I'm pretty sure I'm gonna hate
it
open it oh so this is gonna be amazing
just come walk with me welcome you from
oh my god we have to write a song lyric
plus sing and perform on the large steps
yeah so this is my breaking or a break
moment so David don't [ __ ] this up for
you I got you
all right so let's write a song let's
find somebody
Dean dude I'm actually here at the
stairs bro like I'm super excited this
is like a dream come true bro I feel
like Alicia Keys could come behind me I
don't know where and just go like from
Alabama I'm here alright so you bet it's
like the best song ever let's think okay
let's write something about all the
things that we see around here
Elmo tried to kill us hot dog man trying
to kill us got hit by a bus here in
times where there's pulse so let's write
this first word pose for the camera Elmo
was great ok the hot dog was mad dad
loves we gotta hurry we only have 7
minutes left we stuck that song writing
this house is gonna be a little bit hard
what makes this pair of stairs different
than any other stairs you've ever been
on because these stairs give you hope
like it's so much opportunity out there
you're gonna I'm saying there's so many
things you can do this is so promising
for me because it's like I know if I
want to get up tomorrow and go to a
Broadway audition if I want to get up
and eat that pizza bro I think on the
New York City Times Square where it's
happy surprises it's actually pretty
it's pretty relaxing here no one's
trying to steal money from us or do
anything you know it's it's pretty nice
here see told you buddy
it's been such a great experience being
here with you well become friends let's
just write something about friendships
in this new journey
okay I know your harmonies gonna sound
horrible I can tell us sing it when I
hear one sound horrible do what I love
you ready to do this yes what amazing
day is to be in New York City Times
Square where dream come true yes well we
just finished hatched three bro
New York City's feel big we have a
minute left so what can we do let's get
out of here all right
fair enough
Hey I'm sorry in a big old sourpuss
earlier so I decided to get you oh man
thank you and oh I really wanted one of
these just to show you how sorry I am I
got one too this is Jeff wanna give him
a spin yeah let's get ready go
[Music]
one of most amazing parts of today is
that I got a chance to see something
that's totally different people food all
over the place
pigeons a Starbucks I got a chance to
hang out with this guy which was amazing
so after hanging out with me today but
is there anything in Times Square
because we're kind of a different view
on that you don't hate as much it wasn't
the worst thing that I've ever done and
I had more fun than I thought I was
gonna have today's to you I feel like it
wouldn't have been as fun if you weren't
there we got a beautiful voice thinking
in an angelic voice cuz I was like a
surreal moment like he was jay-z
I was Alicia I thought that and we were
just you just going in the thing with
Times Square is I feel like it's only as
good as the company you keep yes
[Music]
you